would you be gay would i be gay be gay  could you say more words so you know how  to answer that  would i be gay  i'll tell you a moment that i felt i  almost became gay i'm 16 i'm 17. smoking  pot and a friend of ours took us to a  downtown boston loft show it's like a  concert in somebody's loft apartment so  we're leaving the loft we're going down  these stairs that are going like this  and some guys are going up and one guy  goes hey and i look up and there's a guy  at the top of the stairs and i go one he  goes where are you going and i said well  we're leaving and he goes you're cute  and i said thanks and he said come back  up and for one second i thought that's a  choice up there that's just going back  up and being gay